that is Elizabeth Banks rocking a
plunging blue jumpsuit last night at the
Hollywood premiere of the new Power
Rangers movie it was really cool to also
see the original Power Rangers who
reunited for the night new Yellow Ranger
Becky G said she loved the old school
sport they're here to kind of just like
give us the the okay the little pilot
Sheldon like you did good kid now Bryan
Cranston's in the movie but couldn't
make it to the premiere he's busy
shooting his movie with Kevin Hart and
Nicole Kidman untouchable but when I hit
the set we talked about his role in the
Power Rangers film and his connection to
the original TV series are the Power
Rangers that's Brian is Zordon the
ancient mentor of the Power Rangers
Power Rangers were a legion of warriors
but check this out here's Brian voicing
a monster called sniz 'red on the
original TV show oh I know that's funny
back when I first started I was 22 23
years old and doing voices and very very
happy to have that job
at the time Brian made fifty bucks an
hour for the gig and didn't even get a
credit for the role alright when you do
Power Rangers boys you will not defeat
me
Kevin very good never that's the kind of
voices that I would do my voice even
though is much younger it was always
still kind of low so I always did thee
you will not escape me
well Brian has definitely stepped up his
game the budget for the Power Rangers
movie was reportedly 100 million dollars
you were born for this this isn't
anything like what I remember the
television show I'm glad you said that
because when I heard Power Rangers and I
saw your name I was like what Brad doing
Power Rangers Yeah right
it's like why would you do that this is
your destiny it's really entertaining
this iteration of this story it takes it
to a whole different level this is your
time
[Music]